TAINT THESE GUYS THAT WORK
GREAT REPORT.
YEARS, TELL THE TRUTH.
TELL IT ALL.
TELL IT EARLY.
TELL YOURSELF.
IS HE BACK BRAND NEW BOOK
LANNY DAVIS CALLED THE
UNMAKING OF THE PRESIDENT
2016.
HOW THE FBI DIRECTOR JAMES
COMEY COST HILLARY CLINTON
THE PRESIDENCY.
I DISAGREE WITH THE
CONCLUSION.
FORMER WHITE HOUSE SPECIAL
COUNSEL TO THE PRESIDENT
LANNY DAVIS.
HERE WHAT HAPPENS WE KNOW IN
THIS CASE.
WE CAN'T EVEN ARGUE
POLITICS, ESPECIALLY WITH
THE CLINTONS BECAUSE YOU
JUST LOVE THE CLINTONS.
BUT HERE'S WHAT WE DO KNOW
TONIGHT AND I THINK YOU WILL
AGREE, ACTUALLY.
SO WE KNOW THAT WHAT THEY
ARE REPORTING IN THE SENATE
REPORT IS THAT MR. STEELE
GATHERED MUCH OF HIS
INFORMATION FROM RUSSIAN
GOVERNMENT SOURCES INSIDE OF
RUSSIA.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT HILLARY
ASSOCIATES, ACCORDING TO
THIS MEMO TONIGHT, ALSO WERE
FEEDING STEELE INFORMATION.
WE KNOW THAT STEELE WAS PAID
BY CLINTON AND THE DNC
THROUGH THE LAW FIRM.
PAGE AND THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN
WAS BECAUSE OF THE STEELE
DOSSIER.
NOT VERIFIED.
PAID FOR BY AN OPPOSITION
DID YOU EVER HEAR OF
>> I NEVER HEARD OF ANYTHING
THE WAY YOU DESCRIBED IT IN
MY LIFE.
>> Sean: THE REALITY IS
UNVERIFIED INFORMATION THAT
FOR, CLINTON PAID FOR THE
FISA WARRANT AND BECAME THE
BLOISKT FISA APPLICATION.
>> LET ME GET THIS STRAIGHT.
THIS SERIES IS BASED UPON
NOT THE RANK AND FILE.
>> Sean: NOT THE RANK AND
FILE, CORRECT.
>> JAMES COMEY WHO LITERALLY
WROTE A LETTER FROM AN
ELECTION THAT I PROVE IN MY
BOOK COST THE ELECTION.
THIS IS FBI CONSPIRACY OF
FBI AGENTS?
OVERLOOKED HER MISHANDLING
OF CLASSIFIED INFORMATION,
HER DELETING OF 33,000
EMAILS.
ACID WASHED, BLEACH BIT AND
THEN BUSTING UP DEVICES SO
THAT SHE COULD CONTINUE.
THEY WROTE AN EXONERATION
BEFORE AN INVESTIGATION.
THEY WERE WRITING THE
EXONERATION IN MAY.
>> I WILL EXPLAIN THAT IF
YOU WANT.
>> Sean: DAN.
>> IT'S INTERESTING BY THE
WAY HOW LANNY NEVER ANSWERS
YOUR QUESTION AND
IMMEDIATELY WENT TO THE
CONSPIRACY THEORY LOOK AT
THE MEMO TONIGHT IS DAMNING.
HILLARY CLINTON'S TEAM
ESSENTIALLY HIJACKED THE FBI
WERE GIVING TO A FORMER
BRITISH SPY TO GET IT IN
FRONT OF A JUDGE TO SPY ON
THEIR POLITICAL OPPONENT.
THAT'S NOT IN DISPUTE
ANYMORE AFTER TONIGHT.
OKAY?
WE NOW KNOW THIS HAPPENED.
THIS IS SO DEEPLY DISTURBING
I CAN'T BELIEVE HE IS NOT
HORRIFIED BY IT.
>> Sean: BUT, WAIT A MINUTE.
>>
TO GET A WARRANT ON OPPOSING
THINK YOU WANT ELECTION
INTEGRITY.
THAT'S WHAT YOUR BOOK IS ALL
ABOUT.
WHY DOESN'T THIS BOTHER YOU
AS MUCH.
>> LET'S START WITH THE FACT
>> ISN'T EXACTLY LISTENING
TO YOU AND A REPUBLICAN
DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL WHO
DONALD TRUMP PRAISED ISN'T
EXACTLY LISTENING TO YOU AND
GREGG AND WITH ALL DUE
I'M NOT SURE ABOUT YOUR
ANALOGY.
DID I SAY THAT THERE IS A